culture always establish on
social ranking rankings between those
who cultivated and reach it and advanced
it it and those who avoided disdain or
ignored it who were excluded from
culture for social and economic reasons
up until our time there were cultured
and uncultured people and between those
two extremes people who were more or
less culture or more or less and culture
this classification was quite clear for
the whole world because the same system
of values cultural criteria and ways of
thinking judging and behaving applied to
everyone nowadays everything has changed
the notion of culture has expanded so
much that it has simply vanished
although no one dares to openly
acknowledge it we wanted to do away with
the elites who morally disgusted us with
a privileged disparaging and
discriminatory sarcasm whose very name
clash with our Eagle Italian ideas other
time from the different trenches we were
refuting and eliminating that exclusive
corpse of parents who believe they were
superior who bragged about how they had
monopolized knowledge moral values
spiritual elegance and good taste but
what we obtain is a Pyrrhic beast
victory a cure worse than the disease
living in confusion in a world in which
paradoxically everything and nothing is
culture since there is no way to know
exactly what culture is in the most
cultivated circumstances and societies
in history culture consisted of
hierarchies in the broad range of
insights that foreknowledge
on an all encompassing morality
requiring freedom and enabling
expression of the great diversity of
humanity but firm in its rejection of
all that vilifies and degrades the basic
notion of humanity and threatened
survival of the species it was an elite
comprised not by reason or bird or
economic or political power but by the
effort talent and work completed and
with the moral authority to establish in
a flexible renewable way an order of
importance of values in the arts science
and technology it must return to this if
we are to avoid moving blindly without
Direction like robots to our our
disintegration culture can be experiment
and reflection fought dream passion and
poetry and a constant profound and
critical review of all certitudes
convictions theories and beliefs but it
cannot be separated from real life
through life life lived which is never
that of platitudes of artifice sophism
and frivolity without the risk or
disintegrating it it may seem
pessimistic but it is my impression that
with an E responsibility as large as our
irrepressible vocation for games and
entertainment we have made we have made
culture one of those show about fragile
castles in the Sun which falls apart at
the first gust of wind thank you very
much
you
where will this elite come from well the
elite advice I had a democracy nice I
really I don't say well you it is not
only democracy it's also cultural is
particularly culture what needs leads
what we should try to fight against is
the idea that the elite is a kind of
privilege of rich people or influential
people this is of cocina intolerable
absolutely well we should be against
this kind of elites but I am thinking in
an elite that is born out of the
vocation effort and talent of people a
society like a real democratic society
in which opportunities are open to
everybody some have this vocation some
have the vocation of philosophy history
humanities as others have the vocation
of scientific knowledge technology well
the cultural elite should be born out of
this three exclusive reasons vocation if
you have the vocation hard work and
talent not everybody has the same kind
of talents not everybody has the same
vocation not everybody is able to invest
effort in the same way well the ideal
democratic culture elite is an elite
born out of talent at fort and vocation
this will not disappear the idea that
elite by essence is undemocratic is
completely absurd you mentioned that the
biggest crisis we are facing is crisis
for education the question is how is it
possible that the richest part of the
world which is the West
is suffering from the scar Isis of
education because i think the society
has advanced too much and the the
educational system has not been
advancing at the same place and i think
there is a kind of Abby's between the
problem that modern societies face and
the kind of educational system that we
that we have we are not preparing
through our educational system the kind
of professionals and technicians and
scientists and humanists that the kind
of society that we have our day needs
and this is something that has I think
what happening i mentioned may 68
because it's very interesting i think in
May 68 this feeling of distancing T into
the educational institutions and the
social reality of our days was perceived
and but the problem is that the kind of
solution that was fine was absolutely
counterproductive destruction of
authority the idea that education was
something that deeply was impregnated
with the idea of repression the idea of
who was so largely you know shared and
if not share in a way that was the heir
of the rebellion of the yell youth
people was contaminated with these ideas
so the destruction of authority instead
of solve the problem of the location
aggravated it aggravated it and until
now we don't have models to follow so we
have to create the new the new models it
is said that
maybe in very remote kind of places that
are now schools and universities that
have found but what is a paradox is that
the most advanced and modern countries
of the world have a guys's on such
crises in education and don't find the
way to reconstruct the educational
system is one of the challenges that we
have that our democracies have in our
days but which is probably an even more
powerful reason next to the betrayal of
intellectuals and the ongoing betrayal
of the intellectuals and that is
explained so beautifully and
intelligently by dossier zucchinis
legend of the quaint Inquisitor that
your whole notion of culture and looking
to the Airbus etc etc etc or the wish
for freedom is overruled by the fact
that people want to be happy and that
happiness and the pursuit of happiness
that's the main core and for happiness
science technology commercial world
images are much more helpful than the
difficulties of your concepts of culture
but what do you understand by happiness
because I think the problem the kit of
the problem is there well hydrogenation
is to be in total agreement with the
with the working with you leave as it is
this is what definition of happiness so
probably the most happy people in the
world are the video people you know
people without imagination without
critical spirit people that are totally
conform with the kind of life that they
have if this is happiness the idiots are
very happy people you know and I don't
want to be happy in this way I prefer to
be very unhappy but enjoying this
possibility of criticize the world that
is around
I I prefer to be unhappy thinking and
imagine a better kind of world for me
and for everybody and for my my my sons
and my family and my friends I don't
think little that will make people more
happy not well it produces a great
pleasure when you read a great book but
after when you have finished the book
the effects are you are more prepared to
be unhappy because of the good little
too that you have read